freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ihr wisst es vielleicht nicht aber
heute ist mein geburtstag und deshalb
dachte ich mir gönne ich mir heute mal
wirklich was ihr seht im titel einen tag
lang fünf sterne essen bestellen ich
würde kein einziges mal auch nur einen
finger krumm machen in die küche
merkt euch ein bisschen angeschlagen
habe solch ein hunderttausendfach
negativ getesteten autos
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt mal an
ich habe mir schon was ausgeguckt guckt
jetzt mal an was ich vorhabe ist sieht
auf den ersten blick vielleicht ein
bisschen komisch aus dass ein restaurant
dafür bereitet dass sie vielleicht auf
den ersten blick ein bisschen komisch
aus weil ihr seht schnitzel spargeld
deutsch spezialitäten
keine sorge ich werde nicht ein
schnitzel frühstücken auch wenn das
absolut okay ist wenn jemand dafür
schämen aber ihr seht auch das
restaurant hat fünf sterne aus 502
bewertungen und ich habe da schon
häufiger schnitzel bestellt dass das
heftigkeit also ich liebe wirklich das
restaurant und wir gucken was die leute
schreiben der q cells und schnelle
lieferung prima fahrer war auch schnell
da super lecker boote freundlich
professionell genau die erfahrung habe
ich auch gemacht und jetzt stehe ich nun
mein frühstück es gibt hier die
kategorie des das habe ich letztes mal
gesehen und da gibt es kaiserschmarrn
und apfelpfannkuchen weil ich mich nicht
entscheiden kann
bestelle ich beide gezeigt und wir sehen
uns ganz gleich angekommen ist leider
eineinhalb stunden später das hat echt
lange gedauert ich weiß nicht genau
warum der name hat halt gerade erst
aufgemacht wo vielleicht sind ja auch
nicht darauf eingestellt dass jemand
zulagen beginnen das bestellt wir haben
hier den apfel pfannekuchen und schau
mal rein
also man muss wirklich sagen der sieht
sehr sehr krass aus und passend dazu der
kaiser sparen ich glaube irgendwie
kaiserschmarren tag ist glaube ich auch
welche liefern und trägt bis darauf dass
er karamellisiert ist verpackungs mäßigt
übels geil pizzakarton das hier ist auch
perfekt und jetzt kommt das worauf mich
heute am meisten freue dass alles zu
essen
ich weiß gar nicht wirklich startet ich
glaube mit dem kaiser spanne lacht mich
noch dran hier bei mir mal wenn wir mal
schauen also erst wirklich so schön
karamellisiert trotzdem sehr sehr weich
kann man schon mal eine gute gabe lippe
in das apfelmus hinein
also der steht auf jeden fall noch nicht
lange rum der ist üblich finde ich der
cast der schmalen experte aber ich liebe
halt auch kaiserschmarrn ist es auch
häufig auf der hütte in österreich und
so der schon sehr sehr weh jetzt
probiere ich hier den april fahren
konnte sieht halt höchsten richtig geil
selbst immer aus wie von sonova leute
ist übelst hettegger ich kann mich echt
jetzt schreiben was ich kann nur sagen
das warten hat sich gelohnt leute anders
richtig lecker mir ist im nachgang noch
aufgefallen dass das restaurant das
essen kostenlos geliefert hat also ich
hatte über paypal bezahlt und die haben
wir uns erstmal einfach storniert aber
trotzdem gebracht ich weiß nicht ob das
jetzt absicht war es hat ein bisschen
länger gedauert hat oder ob es
vielleicht ein versehen weil ich werde
das auf jeden fall beim nächsten mal
wenn ich dort bestelle nochmal
ansprechen damit die aber nicht
irgendwie mir ein essen aus versehen
geschenkt haben aber effektiv habe ich
es zu diesem zeitpunkt kostenlos
bekommen dann schmeckt es doppelt gut
ich werde jetzt mal sagen auch die
bestellung fünf sterne werfer und die
hier darauf auf jeden fall wäre jetzt
freue ich mich umso mehr auf das
mittagessen kommen wir auch zum
mittagessen leute wirklich ich mache
heute einfach nicht ich meine was soll
man auch in dieser zeit machen ich es
einfach nur und ich habe meinem letzten
video mit dima habe ich bei einem laden
bestellt er mich komplett überrascht hat
der jägerhof der auf fünf sterne und
deshalb erst noch mal reingehen aber mir
was komplett anderes bestellen ihr seht
jetzt hier eingeblendet fünf sterne 85
bewertung ich war ja auch so heftig
geflasht des menschen und es ist
irgendwie so restaurant essen was man
sich nach hause bestellen kann ich hoffe
ihr versteht was ich meine weil viele
sachen sind immer so pizza döner bürger
das ist so klassisches liefer essen und
hier gibt es wirklich wäre wäre sachen
flammkuchen sind scheinbar sehr beliebt
cordon bleu sehr sehr wild brioche
burger bürger bin ich ein bisschen raus
gerade dieser peta tour auflauf der war
so kraft dann erst mal aber ich werde
mich zwar das gleiche im video bestellen
glaube tatsächlich noch relativ kurzen
prozess und bestellen mir das cordon
bleu wann haben sie das cordon bleu
gegessen ich habe es mir noch nie selbst
gekocht dass ich das in ein restaurant
geplant ist locker zwei jahre her
deshalb
eine abwechslung zu dem ganzen alltags
essen und wir sehen specials da ist
freude da ist das ding muss erst mal
sagen relativ klein ist weil er auf 4 10
euro aber es ist ja auch feind weil wenn
wir hier mal reinschauen mit sondern
irgendwas oben drauf ich kann euch nicht
immer sagen was das ist das sieht auf
jeden fall fancy aus und gibt mir das
gefühl dass die 14 euro durchaus gegeben
hat nicht ganz so viel war oder bloß
gefüllt hier
ich gebe mir mal einen ordentlichen weit
davon also wir haben jetzt werd ich
werde die frühstück deshalb bin ich die
kleinere portion des gar nicht schlimm
war das richtig heiß ging auch wörtlich
meine also 40 minuten vielleicht also
das cordon bleu man merkt dass gute
qualität die offen verlaufen auch sehr
geil jetzt habe ich ein bisschen rucola
dabei also wirklich das hat mich echt
überrascht als ich damit die mal
bestellt habe weil das ist untypisch so
dass man so gutes essen bestellen kann
ist wirklich untypisch weil das ist halt
ein gutes restaurant eigentlich heftig
gut 5 sterne sowas von verdient das
kriegt man fast gar nicht auf die
ferrando also ich kenne es eigentlich
nur so von diesem laden ist dass wir
zweiter schmecken wir sehen uns zum
abendessen den geburtstag neigt sich
langsam dem ende zu spiel hat geht er
mit ein paar home ist noch und es wird
natürlich noch zeit für ein abendessen
ich meine kenntnisse marie griechisch 48
bewertung 5 sterne glaubt wir können
reingucken aber beste griechischer essen
der stadt schnelle lieferung die stars
ananas wir haben häufig gelesen heute
schon sehr gespannt auch ein bisschen
was auszuprobieren weil ich liebe das
beliebtestes gericht gegrilltes steak
mit feta übels kartoffelchips ich könnte
mir jetzt mal ein bisschen rein und wir
probieren das komplett durch profis ihr
gar nicht auszusprechen kalahari
irgendwas zahnschmelz in der väter käse
im sesam mantel mit ohne exakt das
könnte ich mir auch noch rein dann habe
ich heute wirklich gegessen die einen
könig und ich freue mich dass gleich mit
euch zu probieren
so deutet es ist soweit hier steht meine
bestellung von ich bin echt gespannt was
was ist das hier zum beispiel schön warm
schönweiß guck mal weiter
okay das sind so diese kann
auch philips kannst du dich dazu kommen
ich probiere mal direkt ein was dazu
sagen die waren übertrieben schnell und
der fahrer war so freundlich also
wirklich die sind ein bisschen
langweilig aber die stehen jetzt halt
auch schon fünf minuten ich weiß meine
oma ist halt echt relativ kleine also
ich habe viel hunger ich dachte aber ich
habe 30 sachen geschlechter werden auf
jeden fall sagt timmermann geil dass sie
ist der gebackene väter der kostet aber
auch acht euro also was schon teuer
[Musik]
das ist jetzt meine essen das ist aras
essen was probierte als erster ich
glaube die bibliothek lieber darauf bin
ich wirklich am meisten gespannt
also einfach so flatscher eigentlich
mehr oder weniger demokratisch
das schmeckt so heftig gegrillt ich weiß
nicht wie man es anders beschreiben kann
die machen das war ich echt da stand was
von den harzer grill oder sowas heftig
geschmacksintensiv richtigkeit wird das
ist wirklich lecker aber wenn ich das
also ist auf jeden fall ab einem
teureren ende des spektrums aber
mittagessen was auch dort fünf sterne
ich halte auch so dafür müssen leute
eine qualität die van die kostet halt
auch so ein bisschen ihren preis diese
im safe deutlich kleiner
wenn man zum beispiel ist so stark wie
jetzt fünf minuten werden halt ein
bisschen langweilig war der käse drauf
auch hier ist sehr gespannt auf die von
peter käser hier ummantelt ist so sieht
das ganze aus der ist auf jeden fall
nicht flüssig darin sondern sehr normal
geblieben ich probiere erteilt also ist
sehr lecker muss ich sagen echt sehr
sehr lecker also die umwandlung wenn man
darauf so diesem sirup dran hat das ist
das ein bisschen wie diese kannst du
diese saison riegel
so geschmeckt hat wo also ich würde
trotzdem sagen preis leistungsmäßig ist
es das ist der platz 3 von heute würde
ich sagen das ist trotzdem fünf sterne
verdient hat 200 pro lieferung die
verdammt war freilich essen ist heftig
gut heftigen qualität waren tag nach
meinem geschmack aber man kann nicht
jeden tag geburtstag hat man kann leider
auch nicht jeden tag die video drin die
man nur fünf sterne essen besteht ja
weiß vielleicht ist dann ein paar
zweiter richtig gut gefällt und würd ich
sagen noch kurze info an diejenigen die
wie jeden sonntag eigentlich mit
nachfolge persönlicher koch gerechnet
haben ich habe es diese woche einfach
nicht geschafft ich hatte meinen
geburtstag ein zwei sachen geplant und
da gab es recht ein großes hin und her
und plötzlich war es schon samstag also
quasi gestern der tag an dem ich das
video gedreht habe
dann dachte ich okay an meinem
geburtstag drehst jetzt nicht den ganzen
tag da sind ja kopf sondern du kannst
dir selbst was da wir können das
verstehen dann auf jeden fall nach wie
vor große interessante gäste
wir planen für das format und ich habe
auch nach wie vor große lust das hier
ist mittlerweile dadurch dass ich schon
so viele folgen gebracht hat auch ein
bisschen mit reisen und deutlich mehr
aufwand verbunden aber ich liebe das
format und es kommt auf jeden fall
weiterhin deshalb habe keine sorge weil
das jetzt mal ausfällt es geht auf jeden
fall weiter und ich freue mich auf die
nächsten folgen dank fürs zuschauen